when it comes to women yeah what is the  sexiest feature that's not ass or thighs  face you think so teeth yeah teeth  awesome he likes greatly crosstalk he  like he likes a little baby  you know it's slightly he likes big  teeth and a cockey you basically know  what this girl looks like a chameleon  like when they get drinking it's like a  lazy eye care he likes like the parents  can't afford no I don't want like dark  dark no but you like just a little bit  like when they're drinking like when  they've been drinking all day  normal yeah normal lazy eye not lazy  which is that slightly I don't know man  just something  we know a guy big teeth I call them jizz  saucers  [ __ ] respect you so This Girl's Life  you might be my new favorite person ever  foreign